hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome trial
edition of ask Evan today mention a
question from one of our readers Sheila
who asked me to check out her website so
she's a wellness coach please visit this
website and share thoughts so let's go
check it out and see what we can give to
Sheila so this is a website fine my
mineral not quite sure what this is
about here millions dive each year from
health concern because a simple mineral
deficiency really well so this looks
like a templated website looks like it's
some kind of network marketing thing I
see a picture here I see kind of a stock
message I see you know guess a bunch of
different messages from other people but
not really your story there's view my
profile so let's check that out and it's
blank so what I would assume is people
hitting this page would probably bounce
right away if this is some kind of
network marketing thing what I would
advise you to do is create your own site
and drive people to that instead of this
one because this one is probably not
going to convert very well for you at
all the key thing here is you have to
tell your story and not hide behind
somebody else's story so you know if I'm
coming here I'm interested in you and
the call to action is a health interview
with dr. Wallach you know I don't know
who that is I want to hear your story so
I you know put your profile up on here
create your own website drive people to
that page tell your story talk about you
know your own mineral deficiency or why
you got into this business why it's so
important for everybody else to you know
really care about because looking at
this telling other people story or some
general health tips you're probably not
going to get a lot of people interested
in taking the next step so when surprise
me of the conversion rate on this page
is really really really low
I understand why people why the
companies will set this up so you know
if I my mineral probably set this up
because for people who are you know they
don't have any kind of web savvy they
don't how to create a website it's an
easy page to be able to send people to
but the people who end up using these
stock pages will maybe make a little bit
it's better than nothing but you'll
rarely find that the top performers in
any of these programs use the stock
websites so if you really want to up
this in the next level I definitely say
create your own page that has your story
on it why you're really passionate about
mineral deficiency and what people
should do as a next step and try to
build yourself up maybe not as the
expert if you're not you know as if
you're not a doctor if you're not super
familiar with it but telling your story
at least as in a way that people can
relate to and drives curiosity for them
to learn more and want to kind of take
that next step if it's sign up for your
newsletter or sign up to get a free
download or PDF or case study or
whatever order right away and whatever
that next step is because again most
people are probably not going to do
anything from this page may be the
bearer of bad news but if you really
want to get this business up to the next
level I would definitely recommend
creating your own site and going from
there so hopefully that helps for those
of you watching if you liked the video
please give it a thumbs up and it'll
also love to hear you have to think
about this page or give a question for
your own business feel free to leave in
the comment section below I'll always
check those out and really love seeing
them come in so thank you and we'll see
you on the next episode
you